that's crazy
how was the actual ping-pong tournament
oh it was good man so
so like i mentioned before i didn't have
a plan
as to how i was gonna
make a difference how was i going to do
this diplomacy i didn't have any plan up
to that point i had no plan
i was probing and picking and trying to
understand more deeply
without getting arrested but then i got
to play the tournament
so first match i play i play against
china then the second match i was lucky
to play against
north korea which was very lucky because
it could have been
vietnam it could have been syria it
could have been
some other country but i'm sure they set
it up so that an american would play in
north korea
i'm sure so um i got to play this this
guy and um
we start the match so first so first we
walk in the walking is crazy too
because you know the way it works is uh
you have the umpires
umpires walk in the music is playing and
then the player
walks then another umpire and then i
walk you know sound like the wwe yeah
yeah yeah a little bit a little bit
and you're walking and they come in and
there's like maybe like 5 000 fans
right all north korean oh damn but all
north korean mind you
right so these are people that they
probably say hey all you people your job
today has come to this tournament
it it it's not like people randomly
walked into the tournament
everything is planned right everything
is made
to look like something right so i'm sure
they said
this people this is your job today
you're gonna go watch this tournament
so they came and when i started walking
in
i could feel like the eyes of people on
me
like it's crazy it's the most crazy
feeling
i fee you just feel everyone looking at
you right because
i'm a black dude with like blonde hair
with designs in it they've never seen
that [ __ ]
unless they've seen dennis rodman and we
don't even know how much
they've actually seen dennis rodman
right so everyone's looking at you
already just being a black dude from
america you know you come out
you know you have the flag the u.s flag
is up there
you know it's on screen usa so everybody
knows you're american
so you come out and people are just
looking at you
and all the eyes are just on your body
and you can
feel it's crazy you can feel the eyes on
your body it's so intense
so then you come out what is that what
is the
average citizen there what is their like
feeling about americans
about america we're the devil we're evil
and we should all be killed
yeah every single citizen this is this
is what they're
this is what they're brainwashed to
believe how the [ __ ] do they i mean how
do they justify bringing americans in
there to compete
because this is it they probably brought
me there to get my ass kicked so they
can say that look i'll greet
that that that's what i said it's
probably
set up so that i can play the north
korean right so look
our great country defeated the evil axis
of america whatever
not not knowing that i am by far not
that player that you think that you're
trying to defeat
i'm not that guy but but but yeah so um
they you know you you come in and
everybody's looking at you and you can
feel
the eyes like the eyes are on your your
your
body you feel it it's intense so we so
we start to play but
once zero zero starts that's it my mind
is on the match i'm about to
i'm about to put it on you right so so
we start playing
i get the first point whoa yeah you know
one zero
two zero three zero every time i make a
point the the audience goes
um so picture five thousand people going
oh
this this this disapproving weird sound
every time you make a point
the first five point saw i heard was
like this from everyone
i was like holy [ __ ] it's nuts and then
he makes a point
and all of a sudden start clapping makes
another point
well then it gets louder it's like hold
then third point
and it gets everyone's just clapping in
unison
like like how you see on tv clapping
really really loud
i mean this is not this is the
preliminary round
it's not the olympics it's not the final
championship
but yeah they don't know though no
they're just there because they have to
be
they were for their guy and they were so
loud so it got so loud that i couldn't
concentrate
it was just so loud and it was just i've
never been
always i'm the underdog right so that
never happens to me
but it was almost like he was underdog
so i was thrown off my game was really
loud
and then i stopped for a second and i
look up
as i look up i just smiled i just
laughed
and then everyone started smiling and
laughing and i was like
oh [ __ ] that's crazy so i played again i
did it again i looked up my laugh
everyone started laughing there was like
a chain reaction everyone started
smiling and laughing every time i look
up they would i laugh
smile they would laugh and smile so i
said bam i got it i got it i got it i
said
this is where i'm gonna make the
difference this is it right here this is
the chance because
i got the audience now i've captured the
audience right
in their mind normally i should be this
evil american so i should be like ah
shut the [ __ ] up or something like this
but i didn't do that i'm smiling and
just interacting and then i so i just
kept interacting the whole match
as i'm playing this guy and then at the
end of the match
the north korean guy wins right and uh
he like you have to shake hands after
you after you play your match
right um so you come to shake my hand
but you can tell he really doesn't want
to shake my hand
he doesn't want to shake my hand i'm
american right so
he just won this match he wants to shake
my hand as little as possible
so so he comes and gives me this this
weak ass like shake like kind of like
just
puts his hands out and and and you know
kind of wants to touch my hand
and i just grabbed his arm pulled him in
and gave him a beer hug
right what yeah and so my camera is
filming
so my camera is behind me which is my
back his face
right and so i give him a beer hug and
in the camera you see his face
his first like whoa but then he smiles
then he smiles right and he quickly like
gets away but he smiles right so that
was the reason to go to north korea that
smile you can't fake
that's a real genuine smile right so
you know the whole crowd started
clapping and he started cheering
and this was real right because i'm the
evil american
right so there's no way he would have
smiled if that wasn't a real feeling
and by him smiling can probably get him
into some [ __ ]
smiling that an american hugged you
right so
so then i realized that i finally
did what i want to do because if you
think about it
for the rest of their lives those 5 000
people
they're always going to remember this
black dude with yellow hair from america
that
came and showed him nothing but love
he's always going to remember
for the rest of his life there's no way
he's going to forget i'm sure
he's never been hugged by anybody like
me or even an american or westerner
never in his life for sure
he's never gonna forget it the rest of
his life he's gonna always remember the
black dude from america with the
bleached hair and designs came all the
way and gave him a hug
right so that now you you can't change
people you know overnight it doesn't
work like that but what you can do is
you can plant the seed
so the seed is planted in his head and
it's up to him
where he wants to take that seed he can
maybe ignore it
but you can never forget it it's always
going to be there
right so when people start saying oh
america is this america's that
america is this those people and him can
think well
you know that guy did come from america
and he was smiling the whole time
and he gave him a hug maybe
just maybe it's not what you guys are
really saying it is you know
right and that's how you plant the seed
so i was able to do that so the trip was
really well worth the anguish that i had
being there
it was worth it yeah so is mission
accomplished definitely mission
accomplished because i mean
it it could have went another way maybe
i didn't get to play north korea and i
got to play
a syrian yeah then that's it i would
have went there
and accomplished zero so it was the luck
the luck of the draw it worked out and
yeah
so that's [ __ ] beautiful man that's a
beautiful story that's really cool